تقعدوا شركه ارامكو السعوديه من اكبر
الشركات المستثمره في السوق الكوريه فهي
تستثمر في مصفاه اس او ال ثالث اكبر مصفاه
في كوريا الجنوبيه بنسبه قدر ب
63.4% ايضا هيونداي اويل بنك مصفاه
متكامله للتكرير بطاقه معالجه تصل الى 650
الف برميل في اليوم كانت ارامكو اعلنت عام
2019 بانها استكملت صفقه استحواذ على حصه
17% من هذه الشركه تتشارك ايضا ارامكو
السعوديه مع هيونداي للصناعات الثقيله
المحدوده في الشركه العالميه للصناعات
البحريه وهي المشروع الاساسي المشترك
لمجمع الملك سلمان العالمي للصناعات
والخدمات البحريه هيونداي بالنسبه 20%
وارامكو بنسبه
40% هناك امر اخر تتشارك فيها امامك
السعوديه مع كوريا وهو استيراد سول
للهيدروجين الازرق وطبعا ارامكو تسير
بخطوات ثابته لتحقيق
استراتيجياتها الهادفه بان تصبح من اكبر
مصدريه الهيدروجين الازرق في العالم خلال
السنوات المقبله
اذا كما تبعنا مع ميسون مفقده العربيه في
كوريا الجنوبيه تمضي شركه ارامكو في
استراتيجيتها بالتحول الى اكبر مصدري
الهيدروجين في العالم خلال السنوات
المقبله ولنقعد الى عام 2019 وقتها افتتحت
شركه ارامكو وشركه
اول محطه للتزوج بالهيدروجين في المركز
التقني الجديد التابع للشركه في وادي
الظهران التقنيه في السعوديه وفي 2020
انتجت ارامكو ومع احد اقتصاديات الطاقه في
اليابان بالشراكه مع سابك اول شحنه من
الامونيا الزرقاء عاليه الجوده وقدرت
باربعين
وصدرتها الى اليابان لاستخدامها في توليد
الكهرباء
هي الاولى عالميا لسلسله الامداد الامونيا
الزرقاء اليوم او مع تزايد الاعتماد على
الوقود النظيف تجري شركه شلونكم محادثات
لتصدير الهيدروجين الازرق الى اسيا لا
سيما كوريا الجنوبيه واليابان خلال
السنوات الخمس المقبله وفي ديسمبر المقبل
وتوقع ان تصل اول الشحنه تجاريه من
الامونيا الزرقاء الى مدينه اولسان في
كوريا الجنوبيه والتي تقدر ب 25 الف طن
المتري السعوديه اذا ناقت ترسخ نفسها في
اسواق السلسله القيمه منخفضه الكربون
ارامكو لديها هدفا واضح انتاج ما يصل الى
11 مليون طن سنويا من الامونيا الزرقاء
بحلول 2030 وكما تعمل حاليا على تطوير
قدراتها في مجالها احتجاج الكربون
والهيدروجين
حرامكم ان سابقا معادن اوبتين بورد فيرست
اند فندم سرتفيكيشن 2 المانيا